S
THAT I INFREQUENTLY AGREE WITH
LINDSEY GRAHAM AND HE SAID
SOMETHING THE OTHER DAY ON
SEAN HANNITY'S PROGRAM THAT
HAS SAID CONTROVERSIAL AND
HE'S TAKING AND COMING FROM
THE PUTIN WING FROM THE
RELATED PRESS AND OF COURSE
FROM THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WHAT IS IT?
HE SUGGESTED IN SO MANY WORDS
IT WOULD BE NICE IF A HERO WAY
STAFF UP IN PUTIN'S INNER
CIRCLE AND TAKE HIM OUT.
AND CREATE A CONTROVERSY.
I'M NOT SURE WHY.
SO LINDSEY GRAHAM FOR THAT HAS
TAKEN MORE HEAT THAN VLADIMIR
PUTIN HAS FOR ACTUALLY USING
ASSASSINATION AND MURDER TO
STAY IN POWER IN ORDER TO GAIN
POWER, AND IN ORDER TO TAKE
OUT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
SCREEN.
HERE WE HAVE A PIECE IN THE
DAILY MAIL UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
ZELENSKY HAS SURVIVED THREE
ASSASSINATION ATTEMPTS THEY
WERE FOR INNOVATIVE AGENTS
WHICH WAS THE OLD KGB.
AND IT TURNS OUT THE WAGNER
GROUP THAT I WILL GET TO IN A
SECOND IS BEHIND TWO OF THE
ATTEMPTS AND THEN THE CHECHEN
A HIT SQUAD IS BEHIND ANOTHER
ATTEMPT THEY WERE ALL SENT
THERE BY FICTION.
THERE IS SAID TO BE 400
MEMBERS OF THE WAGNER GROUP
BASED IN AFRICA WHICH IS A
MERCENARY A CAUSE I MILITARY
ARM OF PUTIN'S ARMY THAT WERE
PLACED THERE IN ADVANCE OF THE
WAR AND FOILED BY SUBVERSIVE
ANTIWAR MEMBERS WITHIN THE
FEDERAL SECURITY SERVICE
, ACCORDING TO THE DAILY MAIL
THE SUCCESSOR TO THE KGB THAT
SAID THE SECURITY NATIONAL
SECURITY CONFIRMED THE
ATTEMPTS.
ONE GROUP THAT TRIED TO KILL
HIM WAS THE WAGNER GROUP THAT
HAS 400 MEMBERS THAT
INFILTRATED UKRAINE WITH A
KILL LIST.
THEY HAVE A HIT LIST OF
ASSASSINATIONS THEY ARE
SUPPOSED TO UNDERTAKE ON
BEHALF OF VLADIMIR PUTIN AND
THE OTHER GROUP WAS CHECHNYA
THAT IS PART OF THE NATIONAL
GUARD KNOWN FOR THE BRUTAL
TACTICS AND OF COURSE
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY IS THE
TARGET.
HE HAS HELD POWER THREE
ASSASSINATION.
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT?
BECAUSE IT'S WELL-DOCUMENTED
AND OUR COUNTRY HAS ONE THE
UNITED NATIONS AND THEY ARE
WELL AWARE THAT RUSSIA HAS A
KILL LIST OF UKRAINIANS TO BE
DETAINED OR KILLED SHOULD THEY
CAPTURE ANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS INCLUDING ZELENSKY
AND JOURNALIST AND ON AND ON.
AND IN FACT HOMELAND SECURITY
NEWSWIRE, YES I DO MY
RESEARCH, PUT TOGETHER IN
AUGUST 2020 THAT VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S VICTIMS A LONG LIST OF
THOSE WHO HAVE DISAPPEARED OR
MURDERED DARED TO QUESTION 210
THE INTELLIGENCE OPERATIVES
HAVE MANY DOMESTIC CRITICS
JOURNALIST AND INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTERS AND ARTIST AND MORE
THAN A DOZEN DEFECTORS FROM
THOSE IN 2006 AND RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE OPERATIVES ARE
NOT OUTSPOKEN CRITICS HAVE TO
SPECULATE THAT PUTIN HAS
ADOPTED A SMALLER VERSION OF
LINE INTO HAVE SIMPLY FEAR AND
SECURITY IN THE RATIONALITY
AND THEY PROVIDE A LIST THAT
IS A YEAR AND A HALF OLD OF
OPPOSITION POLITICIANS AND
BUSINESS PEOPLE WHO WOULD NOT
GO ALONG WITH PUTIN'S IDEOLOGY
AND ALSO WOULD NOT GIVE A
PIECE OF ACTION.
HE IS KILLED DIPLOMAT, 122
JOURNALIST WHOSE DEATHS WERE
ARRANGED BY PUTIN AND HIS
REGIME.
IT GOES TO THE LIST TODAY ARE
WHY HE TARGETED THEM AND WHY
THEY WERE MURDERED.
SEEMS SERIOUS TO ME.
WILL GIVE YOU A FEW EXAMPLES.
2015 IN THE 19 NINETIES PART
OF THE YOUNG REFORMERS AND
BECAME DEPUTY PRIME MINISTER
AND WAS SEEN AS POSSIBLE
PRESIDENTIAL MATERIAL THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN SUCCEEDED BORIS
YELTSIN HE SUPPORTED THE
CHOICE BUT GREW INCREASINGLY
CRITICAL AND WAS PUSHED TO THE
MARGINS OF RUSSIAN POLITICAL
LIFE AND INFRARED 2015 CANNOT
BE PROPERLY TRAINED THE SHOP
FOR TIMES AND TALK POTENTIAL
PERSONAL CONTROL OF THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE MURDER
OF THE KILLER REMAIN THAT
LARGE.
2013 THE SELF SELF-STYLED
TAKEN IN THE LATE 19 NINETIES
WAS INSTRUMENTAL FOR THIS RISE
TO POWER WITH THE MEDIA
CAMPAIGN WITH TWO TEND TO
SUCCEED AND THEN FELL OUT
LEAVING RUSSIA FOR A EXILE IN
THE UK.
THE DISTANCE EMBOLDENED HIM
THE RADIOACTIVE SUBSTANCE WITH
A FORMER KGB AGENT WHO BECAME
A LEADING CRITIC AND AND MAKE
KILLED HIM BY SLIPPING THE
RADIOACTIVE MATERIAL INTO HIS
T.
THEN FOUND DEAD INSIDE OF A
LOCKED BATHROOM IN HIS HOME
WITH THE NOOSE AROUND HIS NECK
THAT WAS DEEMED A SUICIDE BUT
THE CORONER'S OFFICE CANNOT
DETERMINE THE CAUSE OF DEATH.
IT GOES ON AND ON.
WHY DO WE CARE ABOUT ANY OF
THIS?
NOW WE HAVE THIS DOCUMENT FROM
THE CARNEGIE ENDOWMENT OF
INTERNATIONAL PEACE AND NEOCON
OPERATION NO DOUBT.
THE FEDERAL CONTRACTOR IS
BEHIND THIS.
PUTIN IS NOT SO SECRET
MERCENARIES AND THE WAGNER
GROUP THIS IS THE WAGNER GROUP
UP UNTIL NOW YOU PROBABLY HAVE
NEVER HEARD OF BEFORE.
JUST A FEW POINTS MOSCOW FIRST
TO POINT WAGNER IN UKRAINE
WHEN THE KREMLIN NEEDED TO
FIGHT CASUALTIES FROM THE
PUBLIC TO MITIGATE THE
INTERNATIONAL REPERCUSSIONS OF
A NEIGHBOR SOVEREIGNTY AS A
TACTIC WITH DEEP ROOTS IN
RUSSIAN HISTORY DURING THE
COLD WAR.
BY USING SO-CALLED VOLUNTEERS
MOSCOW REDUCE THE ACTIVE-DUTY
PERSONNEL AND CONCEAL THEIR
PRESENCE INITIALLY.
THE RECRUITMENT OF THESE
GROUPS HAPPEN QUICKLY IN 2014
AND THE KREMLIN TURNED TO
PRIVATE AND STATE ACTORS TO
FINANCE THE EFFORTS.
RUSSIA'S COVERT WAR SPARKED
ALARM OVER INSTRUMENTS OF
SUBVERSION BACK IN 2014 WHICH
ARE OFTEN LUMPED TOGETHER AS A
HYBRID WARFARE THAT IT MAY
SECRETLY DEPLOY A WAGNER OR
OTHER PLACES IN THE
POST-SOVIET SPACE TO
DESTABILIZE THE COUNTRY
THROUGH SOME VERSION.
BY USING MERCENARIES AS IT DID
IN UKRAINE MOSCOW WOULD HOPE
TO SELL CONFUSION TO KEEP THE
WEST DIVIDED AND STABLE OF THE
OBVIOUS THRESHOLDS FOR A
ROBUST RESPONSE.
WHY AM I GETTING INTO ALL OF
THESE THINGS?
WE KNOW VLADIMIR PUTIN IS A
KILLER AND THE ASSASSIN AND
HIS INTEREST IN THE COUNTRIES
THAT SURROUND RUSSIA.
WE KNOW SHE WANTS TO REBUILD
THE OLD SOVIET UNION ACTUALLY
THE RUSSIAN EMPIRE SHE WROTE
IN SI ON -┘- AN ESSAY ABOUT
OVER THE SUMMER.
WE HAVE A PUTIN WING IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND IN THE
MEDIA AND UPROOTING COURT IN
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY AND
ACADEMIA.
YOU WILL HEAR THEM AND SEE
THEM AND THEY TALK ABOUT HOW
THE UNITED STATES MAY ESCALATE
WAR AGAINST PUTIN NOW IF THE
OTHER LAPDOGS TALK ABOUT
NUCLEAR WAR PUTIN HIMSELF
TALKS ABOUT NUCLEAR WAR.
WE ARE NOT ARE THEY DOING IN A
PASSING WAY TO SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT THE UNITED STATES AND
HOW STUPID WE ARE AT OUR
GENERALS?
BIDEN IS CALLED THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF HE IS A
DISGRACE AND DISASTER AND HAS
THE RUSSIANS NEGOTIATING WITH
THE IRANIANS ON A NUCLEAR DEAL
WITH US.
WHAT KIND OF A FOOL DOES THAT
CRACKS I WILL NEVER KNOW HE
PUTS MORE SANCTIONS ON THE
AMERICAN OIL INDUSTRY BUT NO
SANCTIONS ON THE RUSSIAN OIL
INDUSTRY AS A SPEAK.
WHAT KIND OF A FOOL DOES THAT
WHEN WE CAN USE OIL TO
DEBILITATE THE RUSSIAN
ECONOMY, THE PUTIN ECONOMY
RATHER THAN DEBILITATE
YOU, MR. AND MRS. AMERICA?
WE DO HAVE A CLUE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE WE SHOULD BE READY FOR
ANY POSSIBILITY DESPITE
SPENDING TRILLIONS OF MASSIVE
DEBT WE ARE NOT MUSCLING UP
UNITED STATES MILITARY
RUSSIA, AND THE ACCESS OF EVIL
THAT EXISTS.
I DOES THIS MATTER?
BECAUSE LADIES AND GENTLEMEN I
AM SICK AND TIRED OF HEARING
THE EXCUSES AND THE ATTACKS ON
THE UNITED STATES THAT WE
SOMEHOW WILL ESCALATE
SOMETHING WE HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY PASSIVE
R
NATO FORCES